l'information vient de tomber le Conseil
constitutionnel valide l'essentiel de la
réforme dont le report de l'âge de
départ à 64 ans c'est une information
capitale après cette longue séquence sur
la réforme des des retraites et on est
là pour en parler pour analyser cette
décision Guillaume Rocket bonsoir
bonsoir directeur de la rédaction du
Figaro Magazine Guillaume c'était une
décision très attendue par les
oppositions par le gouvernement c'est
Emmanuel Macron qui tire les marrons du
feu d'une certaine manière oui on peut
dire ça puisque effectivement Thibault
le Conseil constitutionnel valide
quasiment la totalité du projet de loi à
l'exception de deux ou trois petites
mesures qu'on appelle en termes
techniques des cavaliers c'est-à-dire
des mesures qui n'ont pas grand chose à
voir avec le projet il doit lui-même et
qui ont été rajoutés et dans le Conseil
constitutionnel considèrent à juste
titre que qui n'ont rien à faire là mais
pour le reste 1 la loi est validée et
surtout et je pense que c'est ce qu'il y
a de plus surprenant le la demande de
référendum sur ce projet de loi et
rejeter semble-t-il par le Conseil
[Musique]
est-ce que cette décision du Conseil
constitutionnel Guillaume marque la fin
de cette longue séquence est-ce que
c'est un film avec le mot fin qui
s'affiche sur l'écran la salle s'allume
et c'est terminé ou est-ce que c'est une
série avec des épisodes des saisons qui
vont continuer et des manifestations qui
vont reprendre peut-être de poubelles
alors j'ai du mal à vous répondre si le
Conseil constitutionnel c'était
contenté de valider la loi tout en
acceptant la possibilité d'un référendum
je pense que la colère sociale se serait
apaisée parce que les gens qui sont
nombreux opposés au report de l'âge de
la retraite ce serait dit mais nous
avons la perspective de pouvoir donner
notre avis à travers un référendum même
si à mon avis il serait pas allé
jusqu'au bout pour des raisons
techniques mais au moins il y avait
cette espèce d'espoir or là l'espoir est
terminée donc je pense qu'il va y avoir
une une frustration je pense que
je ne vois pas de raison direct pour
vous montrer Guillaume que la
frustration elle est toujours là puisque
il y a toujours des manifestations
absolument je crois que de toute façon
il faut il faut dire assez jeune gens
qui sont encore pour quelques semaines
avant de prendre leur retraite et je
suis pas certain et on peut s'en réjouir
qu'il soit représentatif de la
population française mais pour autant
oui on avait projeté sur le Conseil
constitutionnel des espoirs qui étaient
probablement excessif en tout cas du du
point de vue de ceux qui qui en était à
l'origine en disant le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est une espèce de de
super Parlement c'est une nouvelle
chance de rejeter la loi mais non c'est
pas ça comme aux États-Unis alors c'est
ça et le problème de la du Conseil
constitutionnel c'est que c'est pas
vraiment une cour suprême mais parfois
les juges du Conseil
se prennent pour des démiurs et décide
de de de d'outre passer leur pouvoir
mais cette fois-ci ce n'est pas le cas
ils n'ont pas osé et je pense que c'est
assez logique nous sommes en direct sur
Le Figaro.fr sur Youtube vous posez
toutes vos questions quatre points à
retenir de la décision qui vient de nous
arriver du Conseil constitutionnel la
retraite à 64 ans est validé
référendum d'initiative partagée et
rejetée l'index senior est rejeté le
contrat de travail senior et rejeté
alors finalement est-ce que le Conseil
constitutionnel a fait quelques
retouches histoire de dire qu'il était
utile mais bon cette loi a été
parfaitement constitutionnelle ce projet
de loi de toute façon le
la décision était par nature subjective
parce que il n'y a pas eu de violation
flagrante de la Constitution par le
gouvernement c'est-à-dire que le projet
de loi est allé à l'Assemblée ensuite il
est allé au Sénat il a fait l'objet
d'une d'une d'un vote d'une demande de
confiance du gouvernement il y a eu
d'émotions de censure qui ont été
rejetées donc si vous voulez légalement
tout s'est bien passé ça c'est vrai
après la question qui était posée au
conseil si c'est de dire est-ce que dans
l'esprit on n'a pas brutalisé un peu les
institutions notamment pour faire voter
cette loi très rapidement et sans que
l'opposition puisse vraiment
déployer toute sa capacité l'obstruction
donc le Conseil a dit bon ben
globalement oui ça c'est enfin
apparemment il faudrait lire les
considérants que j'ai pas encore vu mais
il semble-t-il puisqu'il a validé il a
considéré que tout était à peu près dans
les clous est-ce que le conseil
constitutionnel a fait de la politique
ce sont des êtres humains il y a 9 sages
on les appelle
sont pour la plupart d'anciennes
personnalités politiques
peuvent-ils se départir complètement de
ce qu'ils voient depuis des semaines à
la télé ce qu'ils entendent à la radio
ce qu'ils lisent dans le Figaro pour
prendre une décision complètement
juridique non parce que en fait si vous
voulez les décisions purement juridiques
elles sont très rares il y a toujours
une part de subjectivité dans une
décision de justice il y a une libre
appréciation du juge et c'est pour ça
que ce sont des êtres humains ils
décident de ça vous comprenez c'est pas
c'est pas comme quand vous avez un radar
sur le bord de la route bon vous êtes à
85 km/h pauvre ça flash et vous avez une
amende là là c'est pas le cas il y a une
part d'appréciation et donc évidemment
dès lors qu'il y a pas d'appréciation il
y a soupçon c'est à dire est-ce que les
juges vraiment ont été indépendants
est-ce qu'ils ont écouté
les pressions des politiques qui
disaient que il fallait il fallait
censurer la loi ou au contraire il
fallait laisser passer comme je dirais
que par nature le Conseil
constitutionnel et et sujet à ces
soupçons parce que il a une part
d'appréciation une part de subjectivité
qui fait que ces décisions quelle
qu'elle soit vont être interprétées
politiquement c'est pour ça mais c'est
peut-être un autre débat que moi je suis
très très réticent vis-à-vis de ce genre
d'instance pour moi le pays idéal en
matière de démocratie c'est la Suisse
ensuite il y a un tribunal fédéral le
Tribunal fédéral considère c'est sur les
institutions suisses qui disent que
quand tu dois arrêter a été votée et ben
on l'applique parce que il y a pas des
juges qui sont au dessus des
parlementaires
d'ailleurs de certaines personnalités
pendant la campagne présidentielle je
pensais examen notamment qui disait que
le Conseil constitutionnel faisait de la
politique a décidé de l'avenir politique
du pays voilà d'où cette expression
assez connue de gouvernement des juges
et bien là en l'occurrence les juges ne
se sont pas pris pour le gouvernement ou
en tout cas ils ne se sont pas pris pour
un super législateur puisqu'ils ont
donné un blanc sain à la loi telle
qu'elle a été non pas voté puisque vous
savez que cette loi n'a pas été votée
mais adopté puisque le la motion de
censure elle n'a pas eu la majorité
nécessaire et avec l'article 49-3 la loi
est passée qui est constitutionnelle
absolument le Conseil constitutionnel
vous le voyez valide l'essentiel de la
réforme dont le report de l'âge de
départ à 64 ans l'autre information
principale vous parlez de la Suisse il y
a un instant-guillaume qui est l'un des
pays où on utilise le plus la démocratie
participative le référendum d'initiative
partagée a été rejeté alors on va
comprendre peut-être pourquoi au fur et
à mesure on va nous l'expliquer
est-ce que vous avez déjà des pistes
pourquoi ce référendum a été rejeté non
je dois vous dire que ça ça me surprend
plus
parce que
il y a un certain nombre de conditions
pour que c'est compliqué mais on peut
prendre le temps alors il y a un certain
nombre de conditions pour que ce
référendum d'initiative partagé puisse
être mené à son terme je vous coupe un
instant parce que je vous montre la
première réaction des des insoumis à
l'Assemblée nationale n'a-t-il panneau
la parole après l'annonce du Conseil
constitutionnel de valider cette réforme
évidemment renforcer alors ceci étant
dit que la loi soit jugée
constitutionnelle ne fait pas que notre
opposition c'est de lui contre cette
réforme des retraites à 64 ans et je
veux que partout soit entendu ce message
si la loi est jugée constitutionnelle
cela ne change rien sur le fait que nous
pensons toujours et nous continuerons de
penser et de redire que cette loi est
injuste et inutile et après trois mois
de la mobilisation la plus puissante que
nous ayons eu depuis 50 ans dans ce pays
le blocage du pays reste après cette
décision absolument totale et l'impasse
démocratique de même vous avez vu
aujourd'hui que ça soit par bateau par
camion ou autre à chaque fois que le
Président de la République séminise sa
première ministre ou les parlementaires
sortent ils sont interpellés sur cette
question et nous le disons cette réforme
des retraites va empoisonner durablement
le quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron s'il
continue à vouloir persister sur cette
question alors bien sûr du côté de la
népès nous continuerons à aller soutenir
l'ensemble des mobilisations l'ensemble
des grèves notamment financièrement et
aussi par notre présence évidemment nous
nous tiendrons aux côtés de
l'intersyndicale pour dire que plus que
jamais
nous continuons le combat et nous
appelons solennellement le président de
la République à ne pas promulguer cette
loi parce que s'il prend mieux de le
cette loi comme le dit l'Inter syndicale
elle-même alors le président de la
République ne pourra plus gouverner ce
pays et nous avons notamment proposé que
l'article 10 de la Constitution soit
utilisée qui permet avant la
promulgation de cette loi de faire
repasser par un vote à l'assemblée ce
qui nous a été volé en tout cas la
mobilisation continue plus que jamais et
nous ne laisserons pas cette réforme
continuer son chemin et nous demandons
toujours aux présidents de la République
à la fois de ne pas la promulguer de la
retirer ou de retourner devant le peuple
parce que je le dis nous sommes dans une
impasse dans lequel ils nous ont mis et
ce n'est pas cette décision du Conseil
constitutionnel qui fera changer d'avis
un peuple tout entier bien déterminé à
ne pas laisser passer Guillaume on n'est
pas vraiment surpris mais la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel
voilà la nuit passe la nuit passe tout
entière on va s'envoyer une Rousseau à
gauche
Eric
coquereliste on continue à se battre
il y a pas de perspective de référendum
ce qui est le cas à ce stade même s'il y
a une autre demande qui a été faite pour
de référendum initiative partagée donc
il y aura peut-être une forme de de
deuxième chance une chance tiracle une
chance au grattage pour pour ce projet
là mais sinon
ils sont je crois dans une impasse parce
que ils ont épuisé à la fois tous les
recours juridiques et tous les recours
sociaux tous les recours de de de
mouvement de bras de fer dans la rue il
y a eu très peu de monde il y a eu très
peu de monde hier globalement le pays
fonctionne correctement il y a pas de de
de vrai blocages des transports ou ou de
l'approvisionnement en énergie donc oui
il parle il parle mais que voulez-vous
qu'il fasse ils ont probablement un
sentiment d'un grand gâchis parce
qu'effectivement il y avait une majorité
de la population qui est opposée à cette
loi mais elle est passée cette peut-être
une bizarrée de de
pour des démocrates qui voudraient que
tout se passe avec l'accord immédiat de
l'opinion publique et ben non ce n'est
pas le cas mais je crois qu'Emmanuel
Macron l'assume vous vous souvenez quand
il a fait cette émission de télévision à
la mi-journée il a dit j'aurais préféré
ne pas faire cette loi mais je pense
qu'elle est indispensable au moins il
était allé au bout de sa logique et de
toute évidence le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est rallié aussi à ses
arguments c'est-à-dire que il a pris en
compte la nécessité de devoir assurer à
terme l'équilibre des régimes sociaux et
notamment en l'espèce de des régimes de
retraite à
de gauche
radical à droite radicale aussi s'est
exprimée Marine Le Pen si la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel clos la séquence
institutionnelle le sort politique de la
réforme des retraites n'est pas scellée
voilà ce qu'elle dit elle aussi elle
considère qu'il y a peut-être une chance
que cette réforme ne soit pas
promulgaire appliquée non je crois pas
parce que regarder la suite de son de
son tweet elle dit il appartiendra au
peuple de préparer l'alternance qui
reviendra sur cette réforme
jusqu'au bout
je pense que Marine Le Pen a raison
c'est à dire que ce n'est pas à la rue
ce n'est pas aux manifestants surtout
quand ils sont violents même si ça n'est
qu'une minorité de s'opposer à à une un
projet de loi qui a suivi la voix
démocratique il me semble que là Marine
Le Pen marque des points parce que elle
a toujours dit qu'elle était opposée à
ce projet mais néanmoins elle elle
respecte de façon me semble-t-il
normal le ce qui est le processus
juridique donc elle dit bah en gros
rendez-vous aux prochaines élections
57 les syndicats vont plier comme
d'habitude et ça c'est l'une des grandes
questions désormais également dans le
monde dans la rue les syndicats ont
réussi à mobiliser on en a beaucoup
parlé ensemble Guillaume c'est vrai il y
a eu du monde dans la rue plus d'un
million de personnes reprises ça pour
rien oui parce que encore une fois le le
la démocratie sociale elle existe dans
la vie des entreprises elle existe pour
régler je dirais au niveau
local
la vie publique mais pour autant ce
n'est pas au syndicat ni aux instituts
de sondage de faire la loi à la place
des parlementaires qu'on l'apprécie ou
non Emmanuel Macron a été élu
il y a moins d'un an il a été élu avec
un programme dans ce programme il y
avait le report de l'âge de la retraite
les Français
on choisit de le remettre à l'Élysée
pour 5 ans certes il lui ont pas donné
une majorité absolue mais ils n'ont pas
donné non plus de majorité alternative à
l'Assemblée nationale et donc il y a une
forme de cohérence dans tout ça donc je
crois que Marine Le Pen a raison quand
elle dit ben on se donne rendez-vous
dans les urnes parce que c'est comme ça
que ça doit être et encore une fois ce
n'est pas bon dans une démocratie que ce
soit la rue qui commande si vous nous
rejoignez cette annonce il y a un petit
quart d'heure un peu plus parce que
c'est tombé juste avant 18h dans les
rédactions françaises le Conseil
constitutionnel valide l'essentiel de la
réforme dont le report de l'âge de
départ à 64 ans l'autre grande décision
et on était en train d'en parler avant
d'écouter les
Mathilde panot là chef de fil des
insoumis à l'Assemblée nationale
décision aussi de ne pas valider ce RIP
et on était on allait commencer à
expliquer comment ça fonctionnait voilà
et et comme on donne les informations en
direct au fur et à mesure qu'elles
arrivent il semblerait que le Président
de la République et l'intention de
promulguer rapidement la loi certaines
sources par la même prop ce week-end ah
oui donc ça veut dire que
j'ai vu passer dans l'après-midi qu'il
avait proposé au syndicat de les
rencontrer mardi Emmanuel Macron les
recevra mardi mais pour autant c'était
un petit peu ce qu'on ce qu'on laissait
entendre tout à l'heure avec Timothée
délai ce sera pour leur dire bon ben
voilà maintenant on passe à la séquence
suivante mais ne comptez pas sur moi
pour revenir sur sur ce projet alors ce
référendum initiative partagé vous savez
c'est une procédure qui permet de de
saisir les Français sur un sur un un
projet de loi alors c'est assez encadré
mais les premières étapes avaient été
franchi coup de cela première étape
c'est à dire que 184 parlementaires
avaient signé cette cette demande
ensuite il faut 5 % de l'ensemble des
parlementaires exactement
largement assez ensuite il faut 10 % du
corps électoral c'est-à-dire que il y a
une sorte de pétition qui est mise en
ligne et vous venez de sauter une étape
Guillaume voilà avant il faut passer par
le Français
ça veut dire 4,6 millions de personnes
mais pour qu'on en arrive à cette étape
là il faut que le Conseil conditionnel
est validé le projet de de référendum or
la Constitution prévoit que ces
référendums peuvent avoir lieu pas sur
n'importe quel sujet mais sur les
domaines de l'organisation des pouvoirs
publics des réformes relatives à la
politique économique sociale ou
environnementale et au service public
qui concourent et c'est le deuxième
point ça semble que c'est pour ça c'est
ce que je vous disais au début moi j'ai
fait un peu de doigt constitutionnel
même si il y a très longtemps et donc je
ne pourriez pas
j'aimerais bien mais en général c'est le
dernier job avant la retraite donc
laissez-moi encore quelques mois mais je
effectivement il me semblait que à
l'évidence une réforme des retraites ça
faisait partie des réformes relatives à
la politique sociale parce que sinon je
vois pas ce que c'est que ce que cette
politique là alors il va falloir
regarder pourquoi est-ce que le Conseil
constitutionnel a décidé de refuser ce
projet est-ce que c'est parce que le
le projet doit le texte était très
simple c'était il est interdit de
reporter au-delà de 62 ans
c'est peut-être dans la formulation vous
savez que le Conseil constitutionnel
motive ces décisions donc en fait on va
le savoir mais on n'a pas encore eu le
texte exact et il y avait d'ailleurs eu
une inquiétude du côté des porteurs de
ce projet de référendum puisqu'en fait
ils avaient fait une deuxième demande au
Conseil constitutionnel
n'avait pas écouté c'est possible et je
crois que bien déposer et je crois que
le Conseil se prononcera à nouveau
si ma mémoire est bonne ça doit être
fait avant le début du mois prochain
avant le 2 ou 3 mai sur sur une seconde
demande de
référendum d'initiative partagée puisque
la première était peut-être mal formulée
c'est possible mais encore une fois
comme j'ai pas lu les considérant je
peux pas m'avancer là-dessus bon nous
verrons ce qu'il en est donc
le Conseil constitutionnel rejette pour
l'instant
référendum mais alors même s'il l'avait
validé on en était encore loin et c'est
là que je commence à me perdre Guillaume
alors c'est parce que c'est compliqué
l'idée c'est que
le peuple puisse se faire entendre voilà
sur un sur un un projet de réforme mais
il ne se fait entendre que si le
Parlement ne veut pas se saisir d'un
sujet et donc c'est un peu compliqué
mais bon alors oui mais si vous voulez
le ça n'est pas la loi
telle qu'elle a été adoptée qui ferait
l'objet de ce référendum c'est un
nouveau texte et donc c'est peut-être
là-dessus d'ailleurs que le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est c'est à valider sa
décision l'idée c'est il est interdit de
reporter l'âge de la retraite après 62
ans ça ça c'est le c'était le texte qui
aurait pu faire l'objet d'un référendum
et la Constitution dit que ce texte si
il a il est signé par suffisamment de
parlementaire si il est signé par
suffisamment de français s'il est
accepté par le Conseil constitutionnel
et soumis à référendum sauf si
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
ont d'abord examiné le texte pas
forcément voté mais examiner donc même
si le Conseil constitutionnel avait dit
ok j'accepte que
le projet de référendum initiative
partagé Aya à son terme et bien le
référendum n'aurait effectivement eu
lieu que si
l'Assemblée ou le Sénat refusait
d'examiner le texte or comme vous le
savez excusez-moi c'est que ce
référendum est impossible alors en
l'occurrence en l'occurrence déjà à
l'époque depuis 2008 absolument c'était
sous Nicolas Sarkozy c'est très fort on
disait à l'époque 5 millions de
personnes 10% c'est quasiment
inatteignable on est à peu près sûr de
jamais avoir un référendum en
l'occurrence un sondage on a publié ce
matin dans Le Figaro dit que 74% des
Français seraient prêt à le voter donc
là ils sont accessibles alors si on sort
malgré ça le référendum est encore pas
possible derrière non parce que parce
que effectivement comme vous avez à
l'Assemblée et au Sénat les gens qui qui
sont les maîtres de l'ordre du jour qui
sont favorables à la réforme à
l'Assemblée c'est la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale qui est qui
macroniste et qui a quand même une
majorité relative au Sénat c'est la
droite mais la droite du Sénat on le
sait a voté sans difficulté cette
réforme plus facilement d'ailleurs que
la droite de l'Assemblée nationale mais
vous avez raison même si le Conseil
avait dit oui à ce projet de de
référendum il ne serait probablement pas
allé à son terme et je vais vous dire
cette réforme elle a été voulue pour ça
moi j'en ai parlé avec à l'époque
c'était il y a très longtemps avec les
conseillers d'État qui avait été chargés
de mettre en forme tout ça
notre là je vais faire un peu de
populisme mais franchement c'est ce que
je pense les gens qui nous gouvernent se
méfient du peuple et donc si vous voulez
le
il considère ils se sont les élus les
les
gens qui sont à la tête des
administrations voire même à mon avis
les membres du Conseil constitutionnel
exactement on pourrait les appeler les
élites vous avez bien trouvé le mot qui
résume tout ça ils se disent moi on
demande au peuple et mieux en sport du
coup c'était ceinture et bretelles le
truc était tellement verrouillé qui
pouvait difficilement arriver à son
terme je pense que la gauche qui a porté
ce ce ce projet de réforme des deux de
ce projet de référendum pardon le savait
mais que ils se sont dit on va quand
même tenter notre chance et puis surtout
on va essayer de remobiliser l'opinion
là-dessus il est 18h23 si vous nous
rejoignez nous sommes en direct pour
commenter analyser cette décision du
Conseil constitutionnel de valider donc
cette réforme l'essentiel de la réforme
quelques points ont été retouchés vous
pouvez trouver tout ça sur le Figaro
point fr tiens question Guillaume
peut-être vous n'avez pas la réponse
mais quelle est la relation entre
Emmanuel Macron président de la
République et Laurent Fabius le
président du Conseil constitutionnel
effectivement j'ai pas la réponse à
cette question parce que là honnêtement
alors un cadeau mais en tout cas
Emmanuel Macron sort gagnant de cette
affaire oui clairement bien sûr qu'il
faut le Conseil constitutionnel à faire
cadeau Emmanuel Macron en tout cas il
n'a pas osé se dresser contre le le
président de la République quand je vous
dis que je pouvais pas répondre à votre
question c'est que je sais pas quels
sont les liens personnels entre les deux
hommes ce qu'on peut dire c'est que il
partage globalement la même sensibilité
et on pourrait dire la même chose
d'Alain Juppé membre éminent du Conseil
constitutionnel ou de Jacqueline Gouraud
ancienne ancienne ministre par c'est
vrai mais même mais même au-delà de ça
si vous voulez ils sont dans cette
logique on va dire
libéral raisonnable en économie
consistant à dire bon faut quand même
pas aller trop loin dans les déficit il
faut quand même être à peu près
raisonnable et c'est cette sensibilité
j'irai même jusqu'à dire cette
subjectivité qui leur a probablement
fait valider la valider la réforme ces
images devant le conseil
est-ce que c'est choquant
pour le moins gênant de voir ça alors
oui c'est choquant mais pas comme tout
le monde le voit étonnant là là encore
c'est une question de d'appréciation on
peut réagir de façon très différente
face à la même image il y a cette image
de de rideau
métallique déployés par les CRS il y
avait aussi cette image qui a beaucoup
tourné où on voyait des dizaines de
membres des forces de l'ordre avec leur
casque bleu et qui n'étaient pas des
casques de pacificateur devant le
conseil et un certain nombre de gens de
gauche postaient cette photo sur les
réseaux sociaux en disant regardez c'est
scandaleux ils se ils se défendent
contre le peuple non il se défendent
contre des gens qui qui essaient de
faire pression sur eux et donc sur la
constitution d'une certaine manière mais
absolument absolument c'est de la raison
pour laquelle je pense que les les
responsables politiques même ceux qui
sont un peu trop radicaux comme ceux de
la France insoumise n'organiseront pas
d'avoir une auront pas le droit mais
même ne peuvent pas essayer de former de
mouvement de colère populaire contre le
Conseil constitutionnel parce que parce
que ce serait dangereux il y a des
institutions avec toutes les réserves
que j'ai que j'éprouve vis-à-vis du
conseil je pense que on doit pas faire
pression sur lui Antonio tigreiro nous
dit le premier mai va être très violent
et oui maintenant non qu'est-ce que ça
change que peut-il se passer est-ce que
grand mouvement était un grand mouvement
parce que il y a eu du monde dans la rue
ou est-ce qu'il va continuer
et si si je pouvais lire dans le futur
je serais riche mais je pense que il va
s'essouffler d'abord parce que si nos
informations sont exactes la loi
réformant les retraites va être
promulgué très rapidement et que donc
l'opinion aura conscience que finalement
cette mobilisation n'a servi à rien
alors certes elle va créer une colère je
ne pense pas alors là je prends mon
risque je ne pense pas qu'on aille vers
des mois et des mois de troubles sociaux
graves je pense que les Français sont ça
je pense depuis le début les Français
sont opposés à cette réforme mais ils
sont résignés parce qu'au fond de même
ils savent bien que quand tu as envie de
plus en plus longtemps et qui a de moins
de gens moins de gens qui travaillent
pour payer les les pensions il faut bien
travailler plus longtemps et que donc
aujourd'hui en plus la préoccupation
essentielle c'est le pouvoir d'achat et
ça les gens savent bien que c'est pas de
la faute d'Emmanuel Macron aussi le prix
des matières premières augmente et c'est
pour ça que je pense pas qu'il va y
avoir une forme de convergence des
luttes avec une pression presque
quotidienne de la rue contre le
président de la République
c'est Marie
c'est manifestants donc il y avait prévu
de se rassembler on avait des
informations
de plus de 130 rassemblements dans dans
les rues de Paris une annonce peut-être
qu'on attend c'est celle de Laurent
Berger lui il peut faire la décision
dans un sens ou dans un autre alors il
disait lorsque la voix la loi sera votée
manifestera pas pendant les mois plus or
il s'était laissé une porte de sortie
avec le 49-3 si le texte est adopté par
49-3 là on continuera de manifester que
va-t-il décider maintenant
moi je pense que la sagesse j'essaie de
me mettre à sa place c'est c'est de ne
pas appeler à une un enlisement du
mouvement on l'a bien vu avec les
faibles chiffres de participation
manifestation d'hier les gens commencent
à se lasser et donc chaque nouvelle
journée avec moins de monde avec moins
de blocages avec moins de train arrêté
avec moins de métro en grève et la
preuve que les syndicats n'arrivent pas
à changer le cours des choses et donc ne
serait-ce que pour préserver leur propre
crédibilité je ne vois pas comment il le
ferait continuer éternellement
indéfiniment ce conflit merci beaucoup
Guillaume merci d'être venu sur splato
pour nous expliquer
analyser cette décision du Conseil
constitutionnel alors je rappelle que la
retraite à 64 ans est validée ça pas de
problème que le référendum d'initiative
partagé et rejeté et que dans les points
quelques petits points qui ont été
retouchés et censurés par le Conseil
l'index senior et rejeté ce qui est
étonnant c'est que les télés c'était les
points qui étaient les plus sociaux
entre guillemets c'est à dire les plus
favorables aux salariés qui ont été
rejetés parce que le Conseil a dû
considérer qu'il n'avait pas leur place
dans ce projet de loi qu'ils étaient en
quelque sorte hors sujet on attend ce
week-end avec impatience vous me dites
que cette loi pourrait être promulguée
dès ce weekend signature d'Emmanuel
Macron est-ce qu'il se mettra en scène
parce qu'il l'avait fait au début de son
quinquennat vous savez en venant signer
non peut-être pas certain on sait que le
Président de la République a parfois le
goût de la provocation mais je pense
néanmoins que il va être un peu
raisonnable cette fois on retourne un
instant en écoute les leaders de la
gauche à l'Assemblée nationale Eric
Coquerel le président de la commission
des finances qui s'exprime merci
beaucoup Guillaume
qui a été prise et d'ailleurs il y a pas
mal de constitutionnalisme qui sont
cette année
sur la suite il y a quand même la trame
j'imagine dans des soufflements
comment faire pour congeler sur votre
disposition
de loi en fait c'est une proposition
très simple puisque elle revient juste à
abroger le passage sous un 75 ans et
donc cette proposition de loi elle peut
être à tout moment débattu dès lors
qu'il y a une niche parlementaire qui
vous permet
sur la mobilisation je suis pas seul à
pouvoir vous répondre ça ne dépend pas
d'ailleurs que de nous ça dépend d'abord
des femmes et des hommes qui depuis de
longs mois on sacrifié une part de leur
salaire et ce sont venus manifester des
jours où ils auraient dû travailler et
donc c'est évident que quand vous êtes
un moment où l'inflation galope parce
qu'on parle souvent des retraites aussi
assez largement par les fonds d'achat
c'est assez logique que des gens qui ont
le droit d'achat qui est faible et c'est
d'abord ces métiers là qui sont visés
par la réforme et bien à un moment
finissent par trouver l'addition un peu
lourde et quand ils ont en face d'eux un
président de la République qui continue
à croire qu'il est Jupiter et c'est
forcément parfois un peu décourageant
l'objectif pour suivre Emmanuel Macron
qui depuis le démarrage joue le
pourrissement du mouvement il joue la
lassitude la résignation et c'est la
raison pour je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure que vous êtes déçus mais nous
n'étions pas dépité et que nous étions
dans la déception certainement pas dans
la reddition donc nous allons utiliser
Faure le patron le secretaire national
du Parti socialiste qui s'exprime mais
qui ne veut pas se résigner Philippe
l'abri bonjour bonjour vous êtes
historien du droit avocat spécialisé des
institutions on va parler de cette
décision du Conseil constitutionnel je
vous montre quelques tweets avant cela
se délisabeth borne la première ministre
elle nous dit le Conseil constitutionnel
a jugé tant sur le fond que sur la
procédure la réforme conforme à notre
Constitution le texte arrive à la fin de
son processus démocratique ce soir il
n'y a ni vainqueur ni vaincu voilà ce
qu'elle nous dit elle continue en
améliorant le dispositif carrière longue
et la prise en compte de l'usure
professionnelle qui a travailleurs sur
dire c'est partiront avant l'âge légal
elle continue à essayer d'expliquer tant
bien que mal sa réforme des retraites
Philippe favori est-ce que le Conseil
constitutionnel a fait de la politique
ce soir
ça paraît difficile à dire j'ai pas
encore eu l'occasion de lire le la
motivation et dans les dans ce cas dans
ce type de décision il faut toujours
aller lire la motivation je pense pas
que le Conseil de la politique je pense
que le principal problème c'est surtout
le rôle politique qu'on en vient à
donner au Conseil constitutionnel c'est
je pense que c'est quelque chose d'assez
unique en Europe en tout cas l'habitude
qu'on a de d'en venir à attendre du
Conseil constitutionnel qu'il tranche
des débats qu'on a escamoter devant le
Parlement ou qui ont été pris trop
rapidement et je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui est devenu assez profond dans
le pays parce que on l'a dit le
[Musique]
la mobilisation lors des manifestations
assemblées bccent je suis pas sûr que ce
soit tellement le fait d'une véritable
démobilisation je pense que les gens
étaient un petit peu dans l'attente
parce qu'on le souligne à chaque fois
les gens attendaient cette décision et
ce qu'ils en attendaient trop est-ce
qu'on en a trop fait même peut-être nous
les médias on se disant que le Conseil
constitutionnel à l'étranger alors que
non il ne théoriquement pas faire de la
politique et faire uniquement du droit
bon oui je pense qu'on a on s'est
raconté beaucoup d'histoires il y avait
de l'envie mais il y avait le besoin
aussi médiatique on augmente donc on
envisage toutes les hypothèses on finit
par avoir l'impression que toutes les
hypothèses sont également plausibles ce
qui était je pense pas le cas le premier
réflexe qu'on a eu ce que tout le monde
a eu quand on a appris qu'il y avait ces
représentants constitutionnelles ça a
été de se dire il y a peu de chance que
ça passe et c'est vrai que les jours
passants on a fini par se convaincre que
peut-être ça serait en moyenne de
débloquer la situation etc mais
effectivement c'est pas le rôle du
Conseil constitutionnel le Conseil
constitutionnel on peut critiquer ces
saisons je pense que sans doute on le
fera mais
attendre que du Conseil constitutionnel
que par sa décision éventuellement
peut-être ils viennent mettre de l'huile
dans les rouages c'est pas son rôle et
c'est déjà en soi le signe d'un
dysfonctionnement de notre démocratie
est-ce que c'est c'est rare en France
que le droit d'une certaine manière et
entre les mains l'avenir du pays premier
réflexe le premier idée qui est venu
c'est ce qu'on voit aux États-Unis avec
cette Cour suprême France ça n'existe
pas théoriquement ça existe pas
théoriquement le développement des cours
constitutionnel est quelque chose qui
s'est beaucoup développé qui qui ne
faisait pas partie historiquement de la
tradition juridique européenne puisque
on avait tendance à considérer c'est pas
qu'en France mais partout en Europe que
c'est il y avait pas à une cour il
revenait pas à une cour quelle qu'elle
soit devenir juger le travail
parlementaire puisque la représentation
nationale n'avait pas être jugée par
quelques cours que ce soit et même avec
des mécanismes désignation qui seraient
constitutionnellement prévu et le plus
démocratique possible ça ça crée un
problème bon c'est une chose sur
laquelle la est revenu il y a des tas de
pays qui ont adopté des instances de ce
genre là mais effectivement le rôle
c'est toujours un rôle de validation de
vérification de conformité et a aucun
moment d'opportunités politiques ce
n'est pas le rôle et on ne peut pas en
attendre ça le problème c'est que
souvent on a tendance à essayer d'en
attendant ça parce que quand on est en
désespoir de cause d'attendre qu'une
réforme soit retirer ça devient le
dernier espoir et tout le monde sait que
le dernier espoir ont tendance à trop
l'investir par rapport à ce qu'il vaut
ces images devant la mairie de Paris
devant l'hôtel de ville sur sur la place
devant les anneaux olympiques prévus
pour les Jeux Olympiques de Paris 2024
le Conseil constitutionnel à adopter
d'une certaine manière la réforme des
retraites avec quelques retouches
quelques censures sur certains
cavaliers sociaux c'est comme ça qu'on
dit c'était attendu
ces retouches vous si vous aviez dû
faire un pari avant c'était là-dessus
quelques retouches à la marge mais dans
l'ensemble
parce que c'est ce qu'on a mais encore
une fois toujours quand
on sait qu'un juge va juger
essentiellement la technicité et du
rapport avec le droit lui mais pas
l'opportunité politique on sait que
forcément le le résultat il est il est
limité par le droit lui-même et par ce
qu'on peut en attendre il y avait des
espoirs que la totalité de l'édifice
saute mais ça me paraissait ça me
paraissait excessif au regard de la
méthode particulièrement employée pour
le faire passer rapidement le problème
c'est que pour ça effectivement il
aurait fallu que le Conseil console est
un rôle un petit peu plus politique pas
forcément sur l'opportunité de la
réforme elle-même mais sur la façon dont
les institutions elles-mêmes doivent
être utilisées et on sait que sur le
simplement est-ce que le Conseil
constitutionnel peut se permettre de
dicter au président de la République au
gouvernement quel type de méthode ils
peuvent utiliser
quels sont se demander par exemple
l'opposition se demander espérer que le
Conseil constitue institutionnel disent
non vous ne pouvez pas faire passer
cette réforme via un via le budget voilà
sur le Conseil constitutionnel depuis le
début de son existence on sait qu'il a
une timidité faut pas oublier que
l'activité du Conseil constitutionnel
elle est née la première grande question
qui lui a été posée c'était une question
alors qui pour le coup était du droit
évidente qui était de savoir si le
référendum voulu par De Gaulle en 1962
pour instaurer l'élection du Président
de la République au suffrage universel
était constitutionnel ça ne l'était pas
puisque clairement il utilisait le
mauvais article c'était clair pour tous
les parlementaires à cette époque là et
pourtant le Conseil constitutionnel
avait refusé de censurer parce que comme
ça censure était venue après qu'il y a
eu un référendum et que le référendum
largement populaire avait donné raison
le Conseil constitutionnel ne s'était
pas senti de s'opposer à la volonté
populaire et à partir de là ça un petit
peu limité forcément la capacité du
Conseil constitutionnel à venir
prétendre dire ce qui est pas forcément
une mauvaise chose c'est encore une fois
à partir du moment où vous avez une
Assemblée nationale a eu lieu suffrage
universelle un président universel ça
serait quand même mal vu ou mal venu que
ce soit un conseil constitutionnel qui
est
gommer même si c'est avec des des
mécanismes plus équilibrés possible si
on pourrait faire mieux qui viendrait
expliquer ce qu'on a le droit de faire
ou pas donc tout le c'est un problème
assez assez délicat à gérer surtout que
les personnalités aux conseils
constitutionnel bon là on a un président
qui est Laurent Fabius dont on va dire
la le l'étoile politique commence à
dater un petit peu il y a pas de très
grande figure d'autorité au Conseil
constitutionnel il y a plus de 40 ans
lesquels voilà devant lesquels tout le
monde s'incline c'est il y a pas donc
pour avoir l'autorité suffisante il faut
quand même un petit peu plus que ça oui
d'ailleurs les deux anciens présidents
qui pourraient siégé ni siègent plus
voilà Conseil constitutionnel François
Hollande et Nicolas Sarkozy je montre
votre livre le président absolu Philippe
Fabry vous vous la critiquez cette
cinquième république pourquoi est-ce que
vous dites par exemple absolu que le
pouvoir présidentiel est omnipotent
preuve encore ce soir selon vous
oui d'une certaine manière oui parce que
le problème de la procédure qui a été
employée pour faire passer ce texte ça
montre la dérive de la Cinquième
République depuis un moment le problème
en France c'est que il y a pas de
véritable distinction entre le chef de
l'État et le chef du gouvernement
normalement dans tous les pays voisins
le chef du gouvernement est
véritablement responsable devant le
Parlement c'est-à-dire que s'il fait une
quelque chose qui ne plaît pas au
Parlement il tombe sur motion de censure
dans la Cinquième République ce n'est
qu'une possibilité théorique puisqu'il y
a aucune motion de censure n'a été votée
depuis 1962 et c'était à l'occasion de
l'événement que je disais qu'il y avait
été surmonté de toute façon par un vote
référendaire le problème c'est que
aujourd'hui avec la dérive du pouvoir
telle qu'elle est avec l'apparition en
plus de ses premiers ministres on peut
fantoche de ces premiers ministres
complètement à la main du président de
la République oui c'est vrai qu'il y a
une époque on avait des premiers
ministres presque nommés par par défaut
parce qu'ils étaient ultra puissants je
prends l'exemple de Roca qui est mais
nommé par Mitterrand parce que il a pas
vraiment le choix alors et puis c'est
l'excellent c'est l'excellent exemple
Michel Rocard parce que justement on en
parler beaucoup non mais on en a parlé
beaucoup justement à cause de son recul
régulier au 49.3 il en avait passé 28 ce
qui était très important et donc on dit
aujourd'hui il y a pas de raison qu'on a
un problème sur un grand F3 vu que
Michel Rocard l'avait fait beaucoup la
différence c'est que quand Michel Rocard
engageait sa responsabilité devant le
Parlement c'était Michel Rocard qui
engagé sa responsabilité dans le
Parlement c'était une figure politique
qui avait une crédibilité qui était même
le rival politique de François
Mitterrand aujourd'hui quand Elisabeth
borne va 11 fois en gardant 49-3 devant
le Parlement tout le monde sait très
bien que c'est le président de la
République qui lui a dit vous allez
devant le Parlement et vous engagez
votre responsabilité alors que lui-même
est totalement irresponsable au plan
politique puisque il sait qu'il est là
jusqu'à la fin de son mandat et ça ça
crée un système dans lequel et c'est ça
qu'il faut souligner ça crée un système
dans lequel deux facto le président de
la République qui est le chef de
l'exécutif a aussi le pouvoir législatif
dès lors qu'il n'a pas de majorité
contre lui il est même plus question
d'avoir une majorité pour lui pour voter
il lui suffit de ne pas avoir de
majorité contre lui capable de
s'entendre sur émotion de censure pour
faire penser par 49-3 tous les textes
qui veut ça revient à une espèce de
super gouvernement par décret et
démocratiquement c'est quelque chose de
très très
malsain à longueur de sondage on se rend
compte que les Français sont extrêmement
attachés au vote et au suffrage
universel pour l'élection du Président
de la République est-ce que cette ce
besoin de voter pour le président
pourrait se déliter avec ce qu'on voit
ces derniers temps alors ce délité je
suis pas sûr parce qu'en fait s'il y a
une telle participation en général à
l'élection présidentielle c'est
justement parce que cette élection est
tellement engageante et qu'on s'est
tellement que tout dépend d'elle que on
est un peu prisonnier de cette élections
le problème c'est pas par passion c'est
parce qu'on se dit c'est celle-là qui
compte et les autres le problème à grand
chose ce serait surtout de limiter les
pouvoirs du Président de la République
constitutionnellement le mettre une
espèce de cage constitutionnel pour
l'empêcher le privé de tout un tas de
pouvoir notamment lui enlever le droit
de dissolution pour qu'il y ait plus
espèce de pistolet braquer sur la tempe
du parlant parce qu'on sait très bien
que il y a probablement des députés qui
manquaient un petit peu qui n'ont pas
monter la motion de censure parce que
derrière il y avait la menace de
dissolution donc avec ce genre de de
modification et une autre qui serait
selon moi extrêmement importante et qui
serait d'interdire au président de la
République de présider le conseil des
ministres ce que les chefs d'État ne
font pas dans les pays voisins et qu'il
fait en France et ça ça crée une
distorsion totale puisque vous avez au
moment du Conseil des ministres vous
avez une personne qui est dans la salle
qui préside et qui est celle qui est
Wante du suffrage universel direct et
forcément qui qui écrase la totalité là
vous voulez complètement le rapport de
force c'est à dire que le premier
ministre français devient le personnage
le plus important de la République le
plus important sixième république de
l'exécutif
moi je pense que s'il s'agirait
simplement de revenir à ce qui s'est
fait pendant 100 ans à l'époque où on
était en accord avec les standards
démocratiques occidentaux c'est à dire
ce qu'on retrouve chez tous les pays
voisins et que nous avons déjà connu
sous la troisième et la Quatrième
République alors moi je suis à l'école
on me dit que la Quatrième République
ont changé de gouvernement tous les
trois jours et que
la réforme des retraites dont le report
de l'âge à 64 ans le point névralgique
de de cette réforme et là rejeter un
autre point le référendum alors ça
c'était très attendu le rip référendum
d'initiative partagée pourquoi alors
pourquoi c'est une baisse une bonne
question encore une fois j'ai pas vu la
la la la la la la vous savez que j'ai le
dossier sous la main il est très long le
problème le truc si je me penche dessus
j'ai déjà été bloqué les embouteillages
pour venir donc pour en lire la
motivation mais ma limite ça encore une
fois je je regarderai quel est
l'argumentation le la motivation
derrière en le sens c'est que encore une
fois c'est quelque chose qui sortirait
un petit peu des clous habituels encore
une fois je pense que ça vient du fait
que le Conseil consuel qui caractérise
c'est qu'il est très prudent regardez
l'institution il veut pas bouleverser il
veut pas prendre si vous voulez la
responsabilité d'un changement des
équilibre au sens institutions je pense
que c'est ça qui est assez clairement le
Conseil consuel s'interprète comme le
garant de la stabilité des institutions
telles qu'elles sont et c'était quelque
chose finalement d'asser inédit et qui
pouvait effectivement hypothéquer un
certain nombre de nouvelles décisions ou
procéder d'adoption législative future
donc je pense qu'il y a une prudence sur
ce point-là je pense qui était sur
splato juste avant
déjà je vais être populiste les élites
les dirigeants politiques français ne
veulent surtout pas ça alors
probablement qu'elles veulent surtout
pas ça alors un peu perdu peuple faut
pas oublier que c'était aussi la le tout
ce qui coince par riz ça renvoie aussi
au référendum d'initiative citoyenne
même si c'est pas la même chose c'était
la revendications ça paraît comme
quelque chose de très populiste le fait
est que effectivement ça pourrait
bouleverser l'institution mais ce qui
est gênant c'est que ça envoie surtout
un message c'est peut-être encore plus
gênant que l'adoption de la réforme des
retraites parce que depuis la crise du
49.3 la crise a dépassé les retraites
c'est devenu aussi une crise
démocratique il y a beaucoup de gens qui
se mettent à questionner justement les
spécificités de la Cinquième République
et le fait de rajouter ça en disant non
mais il y aura pas de référendum non
plus je pense que ça va aussi accentuer
dans la durée la contestation
et parce que ce problème désormais il
est sur la table et je suis pas sûr
qu'on pourra le faire disparaître juste
en jouant le on passe à autre chose
d'autant que ce qu'on disait aussi se
réfère un homme la possibilité que les
Français viennent à voter extrêmement
réduite c'est quasiment impossible le
rip il y a un nombre d'étapes à valider
qui est quasiment pas ce sont des choses
qui ont été pensées avec tellement de
garde-fous que on peut s'attendre ce que
ça n'arrive jamais mais ça ça servit
comme ça à donner l'impression que on
faisait quelque chose pour essayer de
traiter la crise démocratique qui encore
une fois date pas d'aujourd'hui mais à
chaque fois elle atteint un palier un
petit peu supérieur dans l'agacement
cette image devant l'Hôtel de Ville de
Paris sur la place de la Mairie de Paris
avec ce rassemblement prévu depuis c'est
pour ça que les caméras étaient déjà
prêtes et avant même la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel au nombre de
manifestants c'était déjà rassemblé
est-ce qu'on a une culture de la
démocratie participative en France
vraiment non on en a pas vraiment on n'a
pas tellement eu l'occasion de s'exercer
alors je crois que la culture
démocratique ça se fabrique mais ça se
perd aussi et ça fait partie des choses
que je sais expliquer sur la 5e
République c'est que lorsqu'on a mis en
place ces institutions cette
Constitution dans les années 60 on avait
une tradition démocratique notamment
parlementaire qui était extrêmement
installée justement parce qu'on sortait
de 100 ans de pratique démocratique et
parlementaires sous la Troisième sous la
Quatrième et cette culture parlementaire
elle s'est progressivement étiolée
effacé en raison de la pratique du
pouvoir et de cette cinquième république
qui de plus en plus attendu à ce qui
consiste en degré zéro de la politique
en fait qui est de désigner un chef tous
les tous les d'abord 7 ans ensuite tous
les tous les 5 ans ce qui était la suite
de la qui était la pente logique le
quinquennat c'est pas quelque chose qui
est venu changer la nature d'institution
c'était dans la poursuite d'ailleurs si
tout le monde l'a voté de manière
massive plus de 70% pour le l'adoption
de du quinquennat
il y avait c'est parce que tout
simplement le s'apparaissait évident à
tout le monde on débloquer la situation
en fait ça n'a fait que qu'empirer mais
tout ceci crée au contraire une culture
du marche de la marche en avant la
marche forcée de la décision à tout prix
au-delà du compromis c'est-à-dire il
vaut mieux prendre une décision vite
plutôt que de prendre le temps de
chercher le compromis et ça ça crée
plutôt une culture contraire à celle de
la démocratie participative qui demande
quand même un minimum de débats puisque
le but c'est de mettre des questions et
de donner aux gens l'occasion de
réfléchir il s'agit pas juste de voter
et de faire régulièrement des votes sur
ceci cela l'idée c'est de politiser un
petit peu la population et ça c'est une
culture qui s'est plutôt effacée
qu'autre chose d'autres images ce qui
nous arrivent celles-ci de depuis Rennes
voilà où les Bretons se réunissent
également plusieurs bretons en tout cas
se réunissent pour manifester et contre
cette décision du Conseil
constitutionnel tiens une précision
également parce que l'un des cavaliers
sociaux rejetés par le Conseil
constitutionnel concerne les seniors
avec le rejet de l'index seniors une
déclaration de l'idée du socle nous
devons avec les partenaires sociaux du
parlementaires trouver les voies et
moyens pour soutenir et améliorer le
taux d'emploi des salariés âgés de plus
de 50 ans oui cette question va donc
revenir sur sur la table on a vu des
images devant le Conseil constitutionnel
hier avec ces très nombreux CRS et
gendarmes qui bloquaient l'accès on a vu
aujourd'hui je voulais montrer des
images avec des grilles est-ce que cette
image est gênante c'est choquante très
particulier alors c'est pas tellement
choquant que on prévoit un dispositif
policier pour éviter que il y ait des
formes de pression qui soit mis sur le
Conseil constitutionnel ce qui est assez
impressionnant par contre c'est le fait
qu'on est dû en venir là et qui montre à
quel point le Conseil constitution
effectivement ce qu'on disait au début
était devenu une espèce de recours comme
ça ce qui n'est pas censé être
une espèce de de oui de dernier recours
pour une population qui ne sait plus
démocratiquement comment faire puisque
elle a envoyé un parlement désuni ce qui
était un signal assez clair de volonté
de remettre au les choses en débat
puisque ces images en direct les gens
étaient satisfaits de cette composition
un peu éclatée et la première réaction
du président de la République ça a été
de nommer un gouvernement qui a donc
multiplié les 49-3 au lieu d'aller
chercher ou donner au moins l'impression
de chercher une majorité sur une informe
comme la réforme des retraites ça aurait
pu être une réforme on aurait pu décider
de ces six mois dessus par exemple si
c'était vraiment important au lieu de ça
là aussi on a adopté ce 49-3 et cela
alors que les sondages alors les
sondages ne font pas la démocratie
évidemment mais quand vous avez des
sondages qui massivement montrent que
la population est contre cette cette
réforme quand vous savez puisque le
président lui-même l'avait dit au
lendemain de son élection que il savait
bien qu'il n'avait pas été élu de telle
manière par adhésion mais qu'ensuite il
va expliquer vous l'avez voté
sincèrement programme bon c'était pas le
premier dans ce cas c'était pas le
premier dans le cas certainement mais
avec disons que si on accumule tous les
tous les éléments ensemble le Parlement
éclaté le président comme ça etc
ça fait un message clair
qui ont une population qui s'est plus
trop à quel sens vouée pour faire
entendre le message finalement à la fin
puisque il y a cette impression que le
passage en force
continue et je pense qu'il y a une assez
mauvaise lecture du pouvoir de la façon
dont justement ces choses ont évolué et
du genre de signaux qu'effectivement
cette situation assez inédite on voit la
suite parce que plusieurs appels à
manifester ont été prononcés hier on a
vu des manifestations on craint des
débordements des violences est-ce que le
droit parce que c'est parce que fait le
Conseil constitutionnel du droit ce que
le droit arrête la violence
le droit a le droit arrête la violence
pas tout seul le problème c'est que pour
que le droit arrête la violence il faut
qu'il soit associé à une légitimité
c'est-à-dire la légalité ne suffit pas
le problème c'est qu'on a un
gouvernement un président de la
République qui depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant parlent beaucoup de légalité
il parle aussi de légitimité mais son
discours sur légitimité ce qui est ce
que je voulais dire sur la façon dont il
était élu il n'est pas entendu parce que
la population ne le croit pas vrai et le
fait de simplement le répéter ne suffit
pas et c'est justement là où ça devient
dangereux c'est quand il y a une
légalité qui s'affirme trop sans tenir
compte de la légitimité que ça crée
débordements parce que ça peut remettre
une mise en cause de la légalité
elle-même et à ce moment-là créer des
instabilités donc le meilleur moyen de
protéger les institutions ça aurait été
effectivement a priori parce qu'encore
une fois je pense pas que le Conseil
constitutionnel aurait pris sur lui de
censurer ce genre de choses de d'éviter
de faire ces espèces de détournement de
procédure qui qui ont été en fait un
objet de scandale parce que il est tout
à fait plausible que cette réforme
peut-être un peu atténuée mais que il y
avait moyen de faire passer quelque
chose
sans recourir à autant d'autoritarisme
et je pense que c'est ça qui amène et le
problème c'est que l'autoritarisme amène
à des images d'autoritarisme puisque ça
renvoie quand même à ça j'ai la force de
voir on voit énormément depuis des
semaines des images de grille de
policiers et c'est pas des choses qu'on
a envie de voir tout le temps dans une
démocratie merci beaucoup merci d'être
venu sur notre plateau Philippe Fabry
historien du droit et de nous avoir
éclairé sur cette décision prise tout à
l'heure par le Conseil constitutionnel
tiens si vous nous rejoignez
malheureusement on va se quitter on va
vous laisser avec ces images quand même
mais je vous récapitule un peu comme je
peux avec les dépêches même si on n'a
pas lu et je vous le conseille vous
pouvez trouver ce long document que je
vais donner pour pour lire et les
justifications du Conseil
constitutionnel donc ce Conseil
constitutionnel a validé ce vendredi
l'essentiel de la réforme des retraites
cette mesure phare de l'âge de légal de
départ à 64 ans elle a rejeté quand même
quelques mesures du projet dont l'index
senior voilà pour la réforme en
elle-même et ça j'en dans le même temps
rejeté une demande de référendum
d'initiative partagée qui a été déposé
par la gauche alors il y a une seconde
demande qui était déposée un peu plus
tard et doit faire l'objet d'une
nouvelle décision ce sera le 3 mai un
peu de temps avant d'avoir une nouvelle
décision sur ce référendum d'initiative
partagée et puis dernière information
alors le président de la République
pourrait promulguer la loi dès ce
week-end ce sont les dernières
informations mais sachez quand même que
l'Inter syndical qui s'est prononcé à
demander au président de ne pas le faire
et elle a aussi indiqué qu'elle
n'accepterait pas de réunion avec
l'exécutif c'était une demande
d'Emmanuel Macron qui voulait les
retrouver les rencontrer mardi à
l'Élysée syndical n'acceptera donc pas
de réunion avec l'exécutif avant le 1er
mai
évidemment faites du travail
manifestation nous suivrons ça merci de
nous avoir suivi on vous laisse avec ces
images devant le Conseil constitutionnel
et puis avec ces manifestations un peu
partout dans le pays excellente soirée
sur le Figaro live
comment dirais-je un pays tout fait dans
la mesure où nous sommes comme dans un
temps auteur
un kilomètre
c'est parti c'était la décision attendue
on va dire le scénario probable
une
balise partielle de la réforme des
retraites
l'essentiel de la réforme est actée
d'accepter et valider par le
sécurité le monde d'un référendum
d'initiatives partagées a été rejetée
donc ça va effectivement plutôt dans le
sens de ce que souhaiter Emmanuel Macron
qui devrait vous promulguer être avec
vous qui devrait être très rapidement au
premier la loi probablement d'ici la fin
de ce weekend
mais rien ne dit
mais rien ne dit évidemment que c'est la
fin de l'histoire il suffit de voir déjà
les premières réactions à la fois
politique il n'a pas de réaction
syndicale pour l'instant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]